Trascrizione: Alessandra Tadiotto
Revisore: Denise RQ
In questi giorni si sente molto parlare
di innovazione, di Facebook, di Twitter,
progetti nati quasi per caso, per gioco
diventati oggi delle imprese
tra le più importanti al mondo.
Cerchiamo allora di capire
cosa vuol dire innovare
e se effettivamente è possibile farlo
anche in Italia.
Quando si parla di innovazione
tante volte si pensa immediatamente
alle invenzioni, alle grandi invenzioni
come ad esempio la lampadina per Edison,
o la radio per Marconi,
ma bisogna ricordare che innovare
non vuol dire
solo creare qualcosa di nuovo,
ma vuol dire anche
prendere dei componenti esistenti,
riorganizzarli in una maniera innovativa
e con quelli creare effettivamente
qualcosa di nuovo.
Quindi non solo l'idea geniale,
ma anche la raccolta di componenti
e il loro riassemblaggio.
Per fare un esempio pensiamo a Starbucks.
Starbucks ha preso il caffè,
un prodotto
che veniva venduto e utilizzato
da tantissimi anni,
e l'ha reinventato, ha reinventato
tutto quello che c'è intorno al caffè,
come si prende, con che tempi, e così via.
Negli ultimi anni innovare è diventato
molto più semplice rispetto al passato,
perché c'è internet, c'è il web.
Attraverso internet tutte le idee
che sono presenti nel mondo reale
possono essere trasportate
sul mondo virtuale.
In automatico si crea un'innovazione,
per esempio Yoox, un sito italiano
che ha portato la user experience
di acquistare degli abiti,
quindi di fare shopping,
cosa che facciamo tutti,
dal mondo reale al mondo virtuale.
Un altro esempio è Evernote.
Tutti abbiamo preso nella nostra vita
appunti con un foglio di carta e una penna
Evernote ha reinventato il modo
di prendere appunti.
Ha permesso di prendere appunti
su qualsiasi dispositivo mobile, computer
e così via, ha permesso
di estendere gli appunti
con delle note, con delle foto,
con dei link,
ha dato la possibilità
di portarli su internet
di poterli riorganizzare,
di poter condividerli.
Quindi ha reinventato
il modo di prendere appunti
e ha creato un nuovo prodotto di fatto.
Un altro esempio è il mio,
io ho operato Skebby
un'applicazione per inviare
sms gratis dal cellulare.
Non ho inventato niente,
ho preso dei componenti esistenti
cioè la possibilità di poter realizzare
applicazioni sul cellulare,
gli sms, la rete, internet sul cellulare,
e ho creato questa applicazione.
Cerchiamo allora adesso di capire
quali sono gli elementi necessari
per creare innovazione
e per sviluppare un progetto innovativo.
Allora, innanzitutto bisogna partire
dall'imprenditore,
cioè dalla figura che ha un'idea,
le idee sicuramente
sono la base di partenza,
sono un requisito necessario
per creare un nuovo progetto,
ma non sufficiente.
Con un'idea difatti non ci facciamo molto,
bisogna provare a realizzarla,
quindi creare un prototipo,
portarla sul mercato,
vedere come il mercato risponde
ed eventualmente modificarla.
Quindi c'è l'imprenditore
che ha questa idea e vuole realizzarla.
L'imprenditore è orientato all'innovazione
cioè utilizza le nuove tecnologie,
crede nella tecnologia
e utilizza tutti gli strumenti
nuovi e necessari
per realizzare il suo progetto.
A supporto dell'imprenditore
come prima cosa abbiamo la formazione,
quindi le scuole, le scuole superiori,
le università,
che sono fondamentali per dare la base
di conoscenza all'imprenditore,
sia tecniche che non tecniche,
per poter sviluppare la sua idea
e portarla avanti.
Un altro elemento sono i media,
che hanno un potere fortissimo
per far conoscere un nuovo progetto,
una nuova idea,
e dovrebbero anche creare
un po' dei modelli.
Oggi purtroppo in Italia
i media si focalizzano
solo sul creare modelli
legati allo spettacolo,
stile Grande Fratello, ballerine,
cantanti, cose del genere,
ma non portano mai all'attenzione
dell'idea ad esempio
imprenditoriale di giovani
che si danno da fare
e realizzano un qualcosa di innovativo.
Quindi anche loro hanno
un compito per aiutare l'innovazione.
Dopo un altro elemento
sono i finanziamenti.
Ovviamente, per poter realizzare un'idea
sono necessari dei soldi.
Soprattutto nei primi anni un'azienda
ha per forza bisogno di soldi
perché deve investire per realizzare
un prototipo, per portarlo sul mercato
per vedere il mercato come risponde,
per farlo conoscere
ed eventualmente per modificarlo
in base alle esigenze dei clienti.
Quindi ovviamente i finanziamenti
sono importanti sia nella fase inziale
che in una fase successiva, per far
sì che l'idea continui a svilupparsi,
e il progetto continui ad evolvere.
Infine abbiamo in fondo il governo,
le istituzioni,
che devono supportare l'innovazione,
in che modo?
Alleggerendo ad esempio la burocrazia,
cercando di snellire un po'le leggi
per fare un esempio noi abbiamo in Italia
leggi sulla privacy
tra le più restrittive, le più complete
in Europa o al mondo.
Ma queste bloccano di fatto l'innovazione,
nel senso che Twitter
non sarebbe potuto nascere in Italia.
Diciamo che nel mio piccolo ho trovato
in Italia tutti questi elementi.
Sono partito da una scuola superiore,
sono andato all'università,
durante un corso universitario
ho avuto la possibilità
di imparare a realizzare applicazioni
per i cellulari e quasi per caso,
così per gioco ho iniziato a realizzare
il progetto di inviare sms dal cellulare.
Questo periodo di università
o scuole superiori
è un periodo molto propizio
per l'innovazione,
infatti se uno ha voglia di far qualcosa
ha molto tempo a disposizione
e rischia relativamente poco.
Nel campo dell'informatica
per creare una nuova idea
i soldi necessari sono veramente pochi.
Più che altro c'è bisogno di tempo
da spendere per realizzarla.
Successivamente io avevo fatto
il mio prototipo, avevo realizzato
questa applicazione e ho creato un forum
a supporto di questa applicazione,
su questo forum ho trovato una persona
che mi ha messo in contatto
con un giornalista che ha visto ilprogetto
e ha voluto scrivere un articolo.
Da lì ho avuto la fortuna
di essere ripreso dal Corriere della Sera,
da diverse televisioni che hanno promosso
e hanno portato in evidenza il progetto.
Grazie a questa visbilità ho conosciuto
due imprenditori,
che sono delle persone che investono
su progetti innovativi
nella fase iniziale dando dei capitali,
sono riuscito a convincerli
e a farli scommettere sulla mia iniziativa
E da lì il progetto ha iniziato
a prendere sempre più vita,
è diventato una realtà più solida,
una realtà insomma concreta.
E oggi stiamo cominciando a portare avanti
il progetto, e abbiamo vinto
anche dei bandi pubblici per continuare
a sostenere questo progetto.
Che cos'è Skebby sostanzialmente,
quello che ho realizzato:
è un'applicazione, come dicevo,
che permette di inviare sms dal cellulare.
Io l'ho fatto nel 2007
quando non c'era l'iphone,
non c'era android,
non c'erano gli smartphone,
sembra assurdo,
ma era di fatto un altro mondo.
E il concetto era lo stesso di Skype.
Se due utenti hanno sul cellulare
questa applicazione,
possono scambiarsi tra di loro
gli sms gratuiti
al solo costo del traffico dei dati.
Quindi, se uno ha una presa flat
non paga niente per inviare sms
ed è esattamente
lo stesso concetto di Skype.
Ho unito, quindi come dicevo
non ho inventato niente
perché ho innovato prendendo
degli elementi esistenti.
Come si vede da questa diapositiva c'è
il cellulare la possibilità di sviluppare
applicazioni sul cellulare,
la rete internet sul cellulare,
mettendoli insieme
si può creare qualcosa di nuovo.
Inoltre, oltre che per le persone private,
è possibile anche per le aziende
utilizzare questo strumento,
infatti ormai gli sms sono integrati
nella vita di tutti i giorni
anche le aziende li utilizzano
ad esempio per comunicare,
ad esempio le parti burocratiche,
quando una pratica è conclusa,
avere un sms è sicuramente molto comodo.
Quindi Skebby è partita inizialmente
da un progetto personale
da un'iniziativa quasi amatoriale,
e nel corso degli anni si è evoluta
diventando non solo un'applicazione
ma si è sviluppata ulteriormente
con un'applicazione anche web,
quindi uno può inviare effettivamente
un sms comodamente dal computer
con una tastiera e successivamente
anche una piattaforma,
quindi un qualcosa disponibile a tutti.
Chiunque voglia realizzare un'applicazione
per inviare sms ha la possibilità
effettivamente e facilmente
di aggiungere un canale di comunicazione
al suo sito o alla sua applicazione.
Il funzionamento è appunto
abbastanza semplice,
diciamo se due utenti hanno l'applicazione
tutto passa sulla rete internet.
Internet permette di realizzare
delle idee innovative facilmente,
è uno strumento indispensabile,
e se due utenti hanno l'applicazione
si scambiano sms tra di loro,
ma è possibile anche inviare sms
al di fuori del...a chi non ha Skebby,
pagando un costo più basso di
quello che si paga al proprio operatore.
In definitiva, quello che bisogna
sottolineare è che anche in Italia
effettivamente è possibile creare qualcosa
Se pensiamo alla mia storia,
è nata un po' così, in un garage,
dal niente, ed è diventata effettivamente
un'azienda vera.
Sicuramente l'Italia non è il paese
numero unoin termini di innovazione
per realizzare questi progetti.
La Silicon Valley ha un ecosistema
molto più ricco
dove tutti i componenti che abbiamo visto
prima sono molto più sviluppati,
quindi è molto più facile realizzare
un progetto di questo genere.
Però anche in Italia è possibile farlo,
infatti il mio progetto è partito da zero
e oggi è arrivato a coinvolgere oltre
1 600 000 utenti, di cui il 30% nel mondo,
e oltre 6 000 aziende ed enti pubblici,
che utilizzano gli sms
per comunicare con i loro clienti.
E questo qua è proprio un esempio
di innovazione di cui il 30% nel mondo,
un servizio nato nel 1993, che è stato,
grazie a internet, reinventato.
Bisogna quindi capire
che se uno ha le idee, ha un'idea,
ha la voglia, può mettersi in gioco,
il periodo migliore per farlo è quello
durante la formazione, secondo me,
perché c'è la possibilità
di prendersi dei rischi,
investendo poco e investendo
solo il proprio tempo,
e quindi anche in Italia
effettivamente è possibile innovare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)